all right people settle in relax  give me a call  this is on the line  are you ready I'm always ready we're  expecting your calls talk to Elvis live  on air and tell him about all of your  issues and problems  radio hosts  [Music]  okay we got Gary on the line what say  you Gary  foreign  [Applause]  [Music]  belong to someone you know no it belongs  to somebody not very nice  and I'm I'm gonna take out his whole  family  Gary what was that I'm breaking into the  top hey Gary stop wait come on why hurt  his family I mean they're innocent  you're better than that Gary  tell me calmly  where exactly are you  your house  worst night of your life  see I've created a game and I think  you're gonna love it  [Music]  this can still end well  we wanted to end well  I don't want to die here  well if we don't want to die we gotta  fight  no how about you tell us the truth we're  all listening show yourself your  slippery Sonoma